everyone Perry here with an exclusive
Collider interview for you right now I
am especially excited about this one
because it's for a movie that I love it
is eighth grade and we have Bo Burnham
and Elsie Fisher here I've really been
looking forward to this
thanks Perry appreciate it thrilled I
mean I can honestly say it whether you
were here or not I would say it out loud
one of my favorite movies of the year it
really struck a chord in so many ways
that I wasn't really prepared for that's
good so Bo I want to start with you did
you just wake up one morning and say hey
I feel like directing a future film now
um no no you know it was a long sort of
weird process like where I kind of came
through the back door adenoids or
something where it's like I did theater
all my life and I love doing theater and
working with actors and I mean I was
fifteen so working with my friends and
cutting scripts and things and then I
started to do stand-up which I really
did sort of fall into and then I sort of
tried to drag everything I loved about
theater and a stand-up and then over the
ten years of doing stand-up I was
writing scripts and things and I started
filling my specials and then slowly
realized like I think the thing I really
would love to do is direct a film I
think that would sort of bring together
all the things I like about all the
stuff I've done without my face which
was the most which is the thing I liked
least about what I was doing it's one
thing than to say I want to make a movie
and then it's another to say I am making
a movie so what you know what piece of
the puzzle what person what story idea
would you credit with saying that's what
made this a reality well I mean what it
was just getting the money I mean like I
you know we wrote I wrote the script
like probably three years before the
movie got money and was just running
around trying to get financing for it
for a few years and I was like it's a
story about an eighth grader and nothing
happens but it feels like a lot happens
there was like no thank you
we will keep our dollars and then
eventually I had enough sort of momentum
in my stand-up where I felt like I could
kind of prove that I could at least
vaguely make the budget back probably so
yeah that was 2016 where
the money is a pretty quick process I
mean some people have stories out there
you know yeah taking like a decade yeah
yeah yeah lucky and I got to sort of
skip steps because of this sort of other
life I had awesome speaking of a very
important step in this process is
casting and one of the things that
always fascinates me about casting a
lead role in particular is the beginning
of the audition process specifically
when you have to pick teeny-tiny sides
to make sure that this person can
actually perform for an entire feature
film so what what did you give Elsie and
then what was it like stepping in that
room for the first time well the the the
first it's funny because I actually
think like a few sides do get it like a
few scenes you basically can see what's
going on so the sides were the initial
sides were her opening video which are
very important it's like a three minute
monologue and then her scene with her
dad at the dinner table yes right so
those are the two right yeah I think so
yeah I don't know I I mean it was very
exciting for me I really liked how Kayla
talked because that's how I talk ya know
I don't know and I mean I was in fan of
Bo's comedy so I was very nervous that
was required for every kid to condition
yeah so I was very nervous walking into
the room but it was like very chill
actually once I got in there and a very
nice environment to be in and like it
was very funny because after that
audition I went to another one and like
I handed them my headshot and they're
like where's all the acne and it was
just so rude of them the entire time
it's so psychotic yeah that's so evil
it really is I'm like please leave me
alone I'm 13
yeah child actor casting people are evil
for the most part except for you yes
well I've buried it a very my a little
deep within myself yeah oh you can tell
between just sitting here and talking to
you guys before we started rolling and
just seeing certain behind-the-scenes
things and certain interviews that I've
watched that you've done I mean you feel
a part of the group you don't really you
know there's and the movie represents
this - actually there's there's no
condescending tone where we're on the
ground level with this 8th grader and
well I think Kayla's story alter her
self is very very strong one of the most
special things about this movie to me at
least is that you can respect her
journey but also you could apply her
journey to everything that you've been
through yeah yeah well that's the thing
I just like that my belief is just that
like what kids are struggling with is
yes in part because they're 13 and their
bodies are exploding they're you know
whatever in their minds mashed potatoes
but also because they're a person in the
world and being a person is really tough
so that's what I hope the movie can do
is that like yes you can see maybe your
kid or your younger self and her but you
can also see your regular adult self and
I do think that uh yeah part of what
kids struggle with is just like the
human condition I do I do think kids
actually have access to that
unfortunately I would also add in just
the value of growth and not necessarily
pushing who you were out into into the
darkness and forgetting about it but
kind of adding it all up because we're a
product of all of our genders like a
movies about kids it feels like like the
main character has to be like wise
beyond her years
like the kids that think they're wise
beyond their years are always like super
cringy and it won't mean it's like
they're like oh I uh Proust and you're
like shut up like you don't know
anything about that so we just wanted
the kid that was a kid and felt like a
kid and wasn't really it she doesn't
need to be quote unquote exceptional to
be worthy of a movie yeah yeah I've been
talking about this movie non-stop since
seeing it with a bunch of friends and I
find it interesting how everyone has
very different reactions to certain
scenes you know some of the ones that I
reacted to I really took to the comedy
and I found it funny and entertaining
and then I had other people who who
almost looked at it like the awkwardness
is so powerful it's coming across like a
horror movie oh yeah
since Sundance especially is there any
particular reaction to a certain scene
that kind of surprised you guys I mean
there's like laughing at the car scene
but it's not it's not even like funny
laughing it's just awkward but that was
a little yeah that was yeah yeah it was
was off-putting I it took a while for me
to realize like that is the waste that
is the reaction yak to be so one I mean
Cayla kind of does it yeah the scene
exactly that's part of what he's doing
slightly is trying to like deflect
things but
no it's great I mean it's yeah it's
really nice to watch it with a crowd and
see like how messy the reactions are
like you just hear like oh you'll hear
people like groaning and what's really
nice is if I'm in a theater and I just
see like heads heads go down or people
bury their heads and like their friend
shoulders and things that's really fun
cuz that that's the experience of being
certainly a being a middle schooler all
you want to do is like crawl out of your
skin
and not watch your own life yeah pretty
much
is there anything that Kayla goes
through in the movie in particular that
brought you guys back to your middle
school experience more so than anything
there's a lot to relate to here but I
would say I have at least one thing that
kind of really dug deeper than more the
smell of a middle school is like when we
walk in like wow that's sort of like
like it's like that like I don't know
like it's impossible to describe when we
went to the art classroom that that
killed me like the actual like whatever
those one of those like chalky crayons
called whatever I sell pastel that's
like I'm smelling like wet soggy old
pastels in the air but also like we the
pool party like we just threw a party
and the kids were just in a pool party
and it was like the sound of like 20
kids like rocking out is maddening and
gives you gives me like yeah like
Vietnam yeah yeah I mean the pool party
was like I mean I haven't been to that
many because I don't have friends or a
pool say just thanks because of that
sure come on let me be sad oh yeah go
for it
pretty good company here I meant middle
school friends thank you um know what I
mean like that was very real and it was
a real pool party and like just the
scrolling on the phone I mean that was
an even middle school specifically but I
was just very real to me and she was
right at him in school so I mean um yeah
it wasn't she went literally from eighth
grade to filming's yeah I had a very
extended eighth grade year the the thing
that got me the most was probably the
stuff with her dad especially at the
dinner table because I have a very
similar relationship or at least I did
with my dad where he's constantly you
know patting me on the back it's saying
good job and I'm just saying that you're
my dad yeah that's that's that's not my
mother yeah for sure but it was like
yeah I don't think people realize that
well no I mean if you're very lucky to
have a parent like that it's still
annoying not like it's great it's like
right I'd always tell my mom my mom
would always be like you're so awesome
and I'd be like thanks like I'm gonna
tell all my the kids at school they
don't like me that my mom thinks I'm
cool let's go yeah sometimes it's just
like I would always feel like give me
something to rebel against please I want
to be like a cool I want to like storm
out of house to be like you know get me
she'd be like I do get you so after all
of this would you say you've been bit by
the directing bug do you want to jump
into another film maybe in the near
future sure I mean I would it's it'll
have to be a it's sort of a
project-by-project thing I think it
would have to be a good idea you have
any ideas nope tell me if you didn't
please hypothetically for our audience
who is super into things like Star Wars
Marvel DC all that stuff and you know
we've seen that trend quite a bit in
this industry where someone makes one
independent low-budget film very very
well it catches on and then all sudden
you get a knock on the door and they
want you for a big-budget picture if
that ever happened to you would you
consider it
mr. Eiger no I don't know I got to truly
be honest and say I don't know it's very
hard to picture me for me to picture
directing something I don't write and I
don't you know I don't think I'd be good
at it truly I don't think I'd be good at
that stuff
sure maybe maybe I'm sure I think that's
that's where we end because you know
while we might have to wait to see what
you're working on next and whatever's
going down you should do it she should
do a superhero movie
much more her doing it than you would
pick a franchise to be in which one
would you pay what would you be oh just
like sci-fi in general or cat lady okay
I don't know I love Marvel Doctor Who it
would be fun but that's also like
British so I can't do that maybe some
sake there though yeah while we wait for
all of this to come to fruition again
guys I can't recommend it enough
go see grade in theaters please please
take your young kids if you're
comfortable with that because you guys
just oh we never talked about that you
had the whole r-rating thing and I
wanted to ask about your experience
doing doing those screenings I mean can
you just yes we did briefly we did fifty
free screenings in one in every state
with no rating in force because it's all
rated but the our rating isn't it's not
a legal thing it's just a sort of a
handshake agreement between the MPAA and
the and the exhibitors so a bunch of
theaters agreed for one screening let
kids in unaccompanied so that was super
fun yeah and you know cuz the truth is
is like yeah the movies got stuff that's
like quote-unquote inappropriate for
kids but kids are living in a world and
they have complete access to all of
those things without context and
hopefully the movie puts it in context a
little bit you know the Common Sense
Media who's like that one of the groups
that recommends things to parents and
things said it recommends this movie for
kids and it's a great quote they say we
can't we can't cover our kids eyes but
we can teach them to see so I would say
take a cue from that tell everybody you
know kids adults friends family whoever
to go see eighth grade bo Elsie thank
you so much for coming such a treat for
me
thank you all out there for watching
this interview don't forget to like and
share and we'll see you soon with more
Collider exclusives
hey everybody Mark Ellis here thanks for
watching this episode you want to watch
more then click up here or you can click
right here for more great content from
Collider if you haven't subscribed a
Collider video do so right now and share
this video for watching
[Music]